le cb que vous voyez les disques et ce
sont des trucs récupéré aux poubelles
pour créer quoi
[Musique]
j'ai transformé ça a un coût steam robot
que vous voyez main qui passe un message
de l'espoir de la musique ça permet
aussi je pense aux gens de se poser des
questions par rapport aux matériaux et
comment est ce que en fait à partir d'un
objet qui est une sorte de revue on
arrive à créer quelque chose d'assez
fantastique assez incroyable
[Musique]
on la trouve celle très sale et ça ça
fait longtemps je suis très très
longtemps
justement ce pour cela nous on refait
ses festivals c'est vraiment pour ça
c'est vraiment pour déranger dans le
déchet qu'est-ce qu'on ferme et 6 2
[Musique]
pour moi les arts et le roman est malin
et paix europe et ça paie moi propriété
à moka parce que tout le monde va ça
chez les ados dégradable réseau baby
sasol
[Musique]
et